there are no images of what's happening
inside managua's chipotle prison it's
where more than 40 government opponents
are being tried behind closed doors for
alleged conspiracy terrorism and much
more
human rights center director vilma nunes
calls it a judicial farce
they've not been able to prove any crime
against these people who have been
practically kidnapped and kept in prison
violating the law and denying them due
process there's no presumption of
innocence the lawyers have had no access
to them until the day of the trial
this is a model of an isolation cell
where nuna says the accused suffer from
cruel and inhumane treatment including
torture
would be presidential candidate felix
maradiada faces up to 24 years in prison
for leading an opposition coalition that
demanded free and transparent elections
last year
his wife who says she and their daughter
were forced to flee nicaragua believes a
guilty verdict is a foregone conclusion
i think the hardest part is having to
console our eight-year-old daughter
knowing that he might be arrested felix
sent her a taped message saying he loved
her and would always be thinking of her
but it's difficult
president ortega began arresting his
staunchest opponents including seven
presumptive presidential candidates six
months before november's elections
he ran and won a fourth consecutive term
virtually unopposed but the elections
were widely dismissed as a sham
four members of carlos fernando
chamorro's family are now being tried
we are facing a great injustice based on
political vengeance not just my sister
christiana but my brother pedro joaquin
and two cousins all of the prisoners are
innocent and are being tried for
participating in civic protests because
they represent the desire of nicaraguans
to hold free elections
former ortega ally dora maria deyes an
emblematic rebel commander during the
1970s sandinista revolution is also
being tried this week on charges of
treason
as is 24 year old lester aleman a
student leader who helped organize mass
protests against ortega in 2018.
ortega has ignored widespread
international appeals to release the
opposition prisoners preferring it seems
to make an example of those whom he
accuses of trying to overthrow his
government
but by tightening control and
encouraging more nicaraguans to join the
tens of thousands who've already fled
the country the trials could end up
making the country's political crisis
even worse
lucia newman al jazeera